hey youtubers is charlie is gonna be my
agents of shield episode 9 video
we have one more week before the
mid-season break saw explained that the
schedules gonna be with agent Carter and
when
shield is coming back date only dropped
a tear gin bomb revealing the episode
I think it was something that we had
suspected all along but I'll explain how
I think that's going to work with the
Cinematic Universe
so givers POS ni absurd if you haven't
seen it yet but starting with top five
moments
number five the Patton Oswalt wins
technically it's triplets
because remember one of them died were
killed when a bomb which they happily
let him know when he came on board the
bus
this is really funny thing Patton Oswalt
said one time he's been working in
Hollywood for a long time
as a scriptwriter are he doesn't really
write scripts so much as he helps
fix them even i think is far back as
maybe like the late 90's
they would call a min for big animated
movies and he would do something called
punch-up
where he would take a script for a movie
to date finished
in make it funnier by inserting like
little jokes by characters of screen
that would say things just to make
scenes funnier
and that's really what he was used for
in this episode he got some really cool
moments but
generally he was like the person that
brought all the jokes into the absurd
technically he was not punch up for this
episode like he was written in at the
script stage they didn't bring him in
after they'd finished it
but I feel like if we hadn't seen Patton
Oswalt joking up this episode
unit bar completely flat like you have
to have the funny moments in order for
the really scary moments to land
it's not so much in easter egg either
but that umbrella
was like that very pain when looking
umbrella was a nice call back to Patton
Oswalt at one point being rumored to
play the penguin in the Batman franchise
panels what would make a perfect penguin
but that's the DC Universe
he's in the Marvel Universe now so we
might not ever see that come to play
but I feel like I was in a shut up for
that especially if you are around
whenever those rumors were going on
I think that was the early days the
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
when that was rumored
or maybe even before that there was
actually a point when panels what was
first casting agency SHIELD last year
when he thought that they were casting
his mod ACH you just something funny he
said
just based on the way he looked like he
doesn't look like your typical badass
SHIELD agent
so he was like my modak is that is that
what they're casting yes
to some great inside jokes he's so good
to playing tension
especially when he has invisibility
umbrellas number four
mark
ebert eases a secret team and a possible
secret Nick Fury plan
peek at that moment in the cockpit where
she said she didn't want to bring hunter
in on the
other thing that other thing is possibly
aside Nick Fury plot
shoes dancing around it but it seems
like she does not want course and
to destroy the city I don't think that
makes for evil like she's not a double
agent
but she could be doing something for
Nick Fury at this point I do feel like
the city is it on
I feel like that's confirmed all explain
that in the second but if you member in
the original Avengers movie
he talks about the peace to weapons the
tesseract based energy weapons
I think the city in the in humans are
going to turn into the phase 3 weapons
type thing early that maybe the idea
that period has
I don't think it's gonna go down exactly
the way the planet but it seems that
mockingbird
might turn on polls and when he tries to
blow the city I do think that they'll
have that big WTF moment where he has
his hand on a button
get 3 to blow it up in Soma jumps to try
and stop them it feels like a very TV
moment so
I a person think they're gonna do it
there's no way the Kevin Feige he would
let them destroy the city and the
Inhumans on TV without ever appearing in
the movies
that's one of the first problems that
having a shared Cinematic Universe
that's planned out far in advance
has a way of circumventing a lot of
attention that you try to create in
television Bay stories
reason the WTF just a couple steps
number three
1833 still has like a really messed up
version
may space just explain her face is stuck
like that
the reason that big scar shows is
because underneath that her face is
really messed up
and the disguising technology is totally
messed up like its used whether
so she stuck like that me not posted a
picture this last week with her but that
messed up face makeup on
I was actually pretty shocked because it
implied that something really crazy was
gonna happen in May
but the minute I was aged 33 you know is
all explained somehow
I do not feel like they're gonna be able
to redeem her like she's gonna have to
die
other you get the sense that she's going
to turn on Whitehall
like she's conflicted I think they'll be
able to break her programming
but you'll still have to die the only
other option for her is to become one of
these new in humans
and I don't feel like he's on that path
I kept waiting for the entire episode
for me to dress that though
do you realize she still wearing my face
who knew May was so vain
it is really creepy though but it was
nice that they'd totally give that
Patton Oswalt joke like right after that
two completely diff like the moment
it was just ok
very well timed joke number two team
calls and find the entrance to the city
but it completely messes Mac up here's
what I think is going down
I think that's an automated defense
mechanism in the city that it turns
invaders against themselves it could
mean that Mac has in human potential in
him
otherwise you know I just turned him to
stoner dust like it does everyone else
out only lead to see like a Mac inhuman
just him
all holdout without actually being the
whole and yes you know I mean he fell
down the shaft
but there's no way that he is completely
dead like whenever the changes happen to
him be clearly made him almost
invincible
so you still gonna come back in the next
episode I don't think they're gonna make
it
into the city until either rainer sky
touches the obelisk to that
symbol on the floor speedy which number
one de ti amo minha course bring
explains the tree
this is like a really huge moment I feel
like it dis did not land the way the
intended ok because
we've been saying Cherie all season long
I think even since last season
there a couple possibilities for the
blue alien at the heat but
really after the first episode in after
they did the big guardians of the galaxy
storyline
Cherie straight up free the real story
now though is in humans
they haven't officially confirmed it
like they haven't said it out out loud
on the show
but if you look at this cover on the
Inhumans comic to the just-released are
they getting ready to release
the symbols near blackballed thrown same
symbols
is the one to the map in the city
causing has so yep court
in humans totally because it is the
second ago one of the big problems
up highly pre-planned Cinematic Universe
is that
you see things coming a mile away if you
want those people that read the comics
this is where DC has an advantage in it
the TV shows the DC TV shows like a row
in a flash
can do whatever they want regards to
what the movies 1 so
there's still some surprises they can
throw at you it is a matter of opinion
which you think is better because
you know sometimes it is fun when you
know that they can do something really
big
you enjoyed the downside being bid you
don't get the big WTF revealed but you
woulda gotten if you didn't know was
coming
in any conversation turns to our sky and
Raina gonna turn into people from the
comics
in last week's video I explain how I
thanks guys gonna get like that
earth-based power she's gonna be because
quakes
I don't think they're gonna change her
face I think she'll still be like lawyer
bennett looking
you may give her glowing eyes or
something like that
but the naked covered giant prosthetics
or anything rain on the other hand i
think is going to have more emotion or
psychic base powers
edges lends itself to some of the
aspects that her character has already
if they don't killer of I really hope
they do not killer of if anyone is gonna
turn into
an actual monster I think it's going to
be skies father
he's already got the doctor jekyll
mister Hyde thing going on I think I
also addressed that in last week's video
so I mean I like that the into this
let me know that what was your favorite
moment from the episode and
which in humans do you wanna see sky and
Raina turn into
to the real biggie string s on the
absurd and I'm not considering the
creamy threat because I was at the E
street level when we first saw that blue
alien
but it was the Bermuda Triangle shutout
Clark Gregg says they figured it out in
the eighties
in 1980 the actually had a storyline
called hold Island
where there was an island that the whole
point to in the Bermuda Triangle
overall I had to give the episode be I
mean it was complete set up for the
finale
so there was a lot of dramatic tension
in we saw the big reveal the Cree reveal
coming
miles in miles away that being said best
performance in the episode
totally Patton Oswalt if you can't give
them a scare
then give them a lap and that's what he
does best so obviously whenever he shows
up in an episode
he's going to do something hilarious I
felt like it was just a bonus that they
give him like the
action comedy moment like this could
have been a schwarzenegger movie from
the 80's like the way they took down
summers 100 people
I will give the show the benefit of the
doubt so next week when we have
the big midseason finale know what they
become we find out what they actually
become
I will give them a giant high five if
they have the balls to like
physically alter one of their main cast
members permanently for the show
that says I like a lot of work every
week for them to
sure that character I'll give them props
I still feel like there's absolutely no
way
we're gonna see the royal family they
might use them or they might be some
Easter eggs
but I still feel like those characters
gonna premiere in the movies
so right now big announcement here the
really important dates about when
shields coming back
when aging carter's happening next week
sugars a break episode 11 whatever comes
back to be march 3rd
agent carter's gonna premier January 16
it'll run for eight episodes
no idea with their big overarching
storyline is but it'll prolly tie in
with the films like it'll be integrated
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
in a small way we're totally gonna see
Howard Stark to cast the real-life
Jarvis
so it's gonna be awesome to check it out
I will be doing weekly video sport so be
sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
to do not
in terms of the crossover with the
vendors to yes there will be characters
from agent to shield featured like to
get small cameos
right now triplet is the only person
that we know for sure
probably cause into you might just get
reference though
Clark break is said he's not in it but
I've heard rumors that he is so we'll
see
all the other characters Mockingbird is
the other one has potential to shop in
the film's
they are doing Avengers to reshoot right
now so if there's any big information
that comes outta that like if the at any
scenes are any characters
especially to show characters I'll be
sure to do bonus video port
so if you're watching this on your
mobile.phone your tablet had new mobile
Inc
appears it seems the link that I had
over here but click here for my episode
a video I talk a little bit about who I
think this guy's gonna turn into
and click here to learn all about Daniel
Bruhl in captain america: three in who
you might be playing which billy may be
playing
thank you so much watching football iPod
I'll see you guys tonight